my name is Bobby Kasturi I'm a assistant
professor at the University of Chicago
and a neuroscientist at Argonne National
Labs what the connectome is is it's a
kind of a newly made-up term for
describing a kind of neuroscience
research where we try to map the brain
at a scale that's never been back before
every person here can leave with
understanding it at some level do you
know why we're here today yes we're
gonna talk about science and we're gonna
talk about a very specific kind of
science about people who study brains
did you know what a brain is what is it
definitely so we're gonna talk about
this is something that people study in
the brain called the connectome do you
know that your body is made up of really
tiny things called cells okay
well there's more cells in your brain
like way more cells and then all the
stars we can see and so what the
connectome is is we'd like to know where
every cell in your brain is and how it
talks to every other cell in your brain
that was awesome Daniel thank you
connectome connectome to be honest I
have no idea that's good that's a great
place to start there are cells in your
brain those brain cells are connected by
wires to each other electricity travels
down those wires and communicates from
one part of the brain to the other part
of the brain and each of those brain
cells makes you know a thousand
connections something like a hundred
trillion connections in one brain in
your brain could I take all of that
information
and put it inside a computer would that
computer then be you computers they
don't have fillings they won't have
fillings and I think that's one thing
that makes the human race wrong I would
say that that map also has your feelings
in it because here's why your feelings
most neuroscientists think come from
your brain anyway and amazingly weather
when you feel happy or sad or angry or
scared
that's just brain cells communicating
with each other so I think today we're
going to talk about a connecting yeah no
it's a map of all the connections
between every neuron in your brain
literally in a human brain something
like the map of the one quadrillion
connections that a hundred billion
neurons make with each other is this
like a map where that's like an actual
visual representation like using
microscopy or just data Wow well I'm
understanding more so that it's these
these the a mapping of the nerve the the
circuitry the pathways between neurons
that can lead to evidence of patterns in
your brain that are common between
different people we have to use electron
microscopes and then we have been
developing our ways to slice the brain
into really thin slices use an electron
microscope to take a picture of each
slice and then use computers to put it
all back imagine that we could get the
map of every connection right and we
knew how neurons fired do you think we
could put that in a computer that map
and then therefore that computer should
be able to think just like the brain
that we extracted it from well the
computer only communicates with itself
in binary so it only has two options it
can only ask itself yes-or-no questions
but a human brain has an infinity of
directions that it can go neurons are
also digital meaning a neuron either
fires or it doesn't fire so that's
either
one or zero and it's the combination of
those ones or zeros that actually
produce the 10,000 different answers
that you say it's a large-scale attempt
to understand the wiring map of the
brain definitely great
I think that it's definitely needed ha
understanding the anatomy of the brain
is definitely important but it doesn't
necessarily tell us everything about the
function so there's some sort of
temporal order from neuron to neuron and
region to region that we may not be able
to pick up this is where it gets really
crazy could we simulate that map inside
a computer and would that computer then
be thinking like that original brain for
which we made the map I mean that's not
that's not the person I mean having a
representation of someone's neural
network is just that it's just a
representation of their neural network
because there's more to the to you in
here than just information passing
between neurons I'd like to think so huh
it would be like if you simulated a
hurricane imagine we can keep track of
every variable of a hurricane wind speed
every water molecule etc etc temperature
and we put that inside a super-fast
computer and we simulated right I don't
think anyone would think that the inside
of the computer would get wet even
though we had simulated the hurricane
perfectly that wetness is consciousness
is what we are is it ethical to imagine
mapping a male brain versus a female
brain to look for differences between
those two explain alleged behavioral
differences between them every single
person is different and so it should be
okay to map every single person's brain
I mean I understand that there are that
it's very sensitive you know you're
sensitive
mapping in Indian brain versus a
Caucasian brain
or politically I think that people may
have some issue with mapping out what
causes or what makes a difference
between huh different types of people
maybe a wiring diagram is not sufficient
to understand the brain and it would be
crazy to think that that would be
sufficient actually if you limit the
connect them to be just the wiring
diagram without you know more
information about myelination or glial
cells correct all types of environmental
features that surround the neurons and
axons then then you have an incomplete
picture right no no sometimes when
people get they worry about connectomics
I think what they're actually worrying
about is that it's the end of the way
that we used to do neuroscience what do
you think about memory do you think that
there's ways of resolving the substrate
of human memories you know is it just
LTP and OCD I'm not sure if you had a
connect home of a human brain of an
adult human I would be able to read out
memories from that you don't think it's
just the synaptic weights like a an
artificial neural network that's trying
to do a particular it could absolutely
be but without knowing what the weights
were before the memory was made what if
you had a violinist learn a piece of
Bach music yes could you find those
notes somewhere in their brain yes I
didn't know before yes you know at I'm a
musician and I don't think it's possible
I think that there are too many you know
so much of it is associative to what you
already know uh-huh and as a musician
how much of it do you think is in your
hands versus in your brains meaning like
you do have connections in your muscles
from the nerves that are from your
spinal cord what if some of the learning
is there are you still doing yeah more
yeah and we do a lot of x-ray in
addition to II M and this is actually
I'm not saying it's the only problem but
it's the only problem that needs to be
solved right away
is that the data analysis right in fact
I think we calculated that there aren't
enough humans ever to map a mouse brain
wherever you collect every connection
and etc so the problem is to get
algorithms to to trace to recognize
things in brains the way humans
recognize things in brains or map things
trace things in brains it's gonna cost a
lot of money to imagine setting the gold
standard for the wiring diagram even
once and that's what I'm those are the
kinds of ethical concerns that I'm
worried about one of the things that
we're not doing well as a field is sort
of educating and telling people beyond
our field the benefits of what we could
achieve but I'm impressed that when you
talk to people about something that
seems kind of crazy and outlandish and
perhaps they hadn't been talking about
before it doesn't take them long to come
to a kind of considered opinion
especially children I think it's kind of
amazing I mean I do hope that more
people talk about brains and what we use
brains for and the ways that we should
use our brains so I think this field has
the opportunity to make that more real